over in california we are seeing the
wages of reality
the left convinces itself that if it
simply wishes for things hard enough and
claps loud enough then tinkerbell will
live but that is not the way things work
when it comes to criminal justice issues
according to the uk daily mail san
francisco bay has now been hit by a
third day of brazen looting with a gang
of thieves filmed smashing cases at a
jewelry store and emptying them as staff
screamed in terror the latest incident
happened at a sam's jeweler's store at
the southland mall in hayward around 5
30 p.m sunday evening and was caught on
camera robbers were apparently part of a
gang of around 40 to 50 teens who
entered the mall wielded hammers to
smash display cases at sam's before
making off with the goods dramatic
footage shot from nearby stores showed
shopworkers screaming in fear as the
disturbing scene unfolded also on sunday
another gang of looters snatched
garments from up market yoga brand
lululemon's san jose store i mean they
need their they need their pants
they need those um they need those yoga
pants
and uh apparently it would be
totally terrible to point out that folks
are looting really bad to point out that
the folks are are looting here because
if you use the word looting then this
implies that black people are doing
eluding well in this video
black people are apparently doing the
looting and there's nothing wrong with
saying they are looting they are
literally smashing cases at a jewelry
store and then just grabbing stuff and
running
and the race is only relevant in
describing suspects because when you
want to catch suspects you actually have
to use their physical descriptors also
the media's refusal to announce the the
race of particular criminals is an
ongoing thing in american media coverage
when it comes to american media coverage
you will notice that any time there's a
white criminal he's described
immediately as a white criminal any time
it is a black criminal the person is
just described as a criminal and that is
because the media don't wish to purvey
the notion that a disproportionate
number of black people are committing
crimes even if unfortunately
disproportionate number of black people
are committing crimes they think that
this will give fodder to racists who
think that there are natural differences
between black and white that lead to the
crime
all of that is the media attempting to
read too much into how crime is actually
covered
but again the fact of the matter is this
is looting and the people who are doing
it should be prosecuted by the way you
know who is saying this not me al
sharpton this is where you insert
graphic
of that onion story worst person you
know makes good point here's al sharpton
a terrible human being who has
incentivized actual rioting in the past
saying yeah you know it's really people
who are kind of limousine liberals who
are interested in in letting these sorts
of of criminals off the hook
a guy or a lady stealing a louis vuitton
bag is not somebody that needs social
uplifting this is somebody that is
really causing us more of a problem
these latte liberals that justify this
this has nothing to do with poverty this
has nothing to do with you couldn't get
a job these are people that can go back
in the neighborhoods where louis vuitton
bag is not unusual and they can just fit
in and many of it for gag and they hurt
the cause of those that want criminal
justice reform
wow al sharpton's saying the same thing
but here's the thing the left has lost
it so much that even al sharpton is like
you guys are way too much for me al
sharpton
like sorry guys i'm not on this
bandwagon on saturday video posted to
twitter showed a swarm of robbers caught
on security cameras stealing
prescriptions from wellspring pharmacy
in oakland at around 7 30 pm pharmacy
employees sped up the footage to show
dozens of people running through the
store to grab boxes of drugs off the
shelves before quickly moving out it's
unclear what drugs were stolen staff say
customers whose meds were stolen will
still be able to collect replacement
meds that have been ordered in store
employees told kgo tv reporter dion lim
they were overwhelmed and devastated by
the brazen theft that's a small drug
store it doesn't have the same resources
as chains like cvs or walgreens but by
the way it is important to note that a
lot of these chain stores have pulled
out of san francisco because of the
crime right this has happened in a lot
of high crime areas around the country
target has shut its doors in a variety
of locales where crime is high
in fact best buy which is a major chain
the ceo cory berry said theft is a
growing problem at the company's stores
they're implementing added security
measures to safeguard employees and
shoppers barry said on a call with
analysts this is traumatizing for our
associates it's unacceptable we're doing
everything we can to try and create as
safe
as possible an environment
apparently best buy said that they are
actually seeing a stock drop because of
the crime surge
apparently it's hitting best buy's
profits it could hurt its ability to
retain and attract more employees in a
tight labor market
apparently some incidents involve
individuals bringing a weapon like a gun
or a crowbar
barry's comments come on the heels of a
string of retail thefts in san francisco
the targeted louis vuitton a burberry
store a jewelry store bloomingdale's
walgreens on saturday a nordstrom
department store near san francisco is
ransacked in what police described as a
smash and grab incident
and it's not just restricted to san
francisco by the way nordstrom's in la
was also hit so this is over by the
grove which is one of the most upscale
areas of los angeles who's also hit
during the riots by the way i remember
the the so-called peaceful protest last
year that burned half the cars on
melrose boulevard they went to the grove
as well it's a place that i used to go
with my kids to hang out to grow it's a
really nice area in los angeles but this
is the second time inside of about a
year and a half that it's now been
looted
so things are going really well at these
at these major cities these major cities
and again it it is not just san
francisco in los angeles louis vuitton
was hit saks fifth avenue on rodeo drive
was damaged rodeo drive is like the
nicest area in los angeles and you'll
recall that last year during the black
lives matter riots
they actually shut down rodeo drive at
1pm in the middle of the riots because
they had to give people space to to
smash things beverly hills said police
said officers responded sunday to
reports of a window smash under the 200
block of rodeo drive when they arrived
they located two storefronts that had
their windows smashed the damaged
storefronts included louis vuitton and
sachs fifth avenue
and as we say nordstroms got hit as well
so things are going beautifully for the
left like they're going they're going
wonderfully for the left and and this is
a left-wing thing it really is it's a
left-wing thing because they've decided
that being soft on crime is just another
form of equity
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang